on s'est réfugié à l'intérieur cette
semaine parce que c'est un tempête pour
une deuxième fois cette semaine alors
radi notre homme est dit stéphane si tu
veux on va rester à l'intérieur j'ai dit
d'accord on va aller à la machine à café
là où toutes les discussions au lieu où
les canadiens se pose des questions il a
bien sûr de ce qu'on est à rci
on sera pose la question mais
internationalement la question porte sur
les femmes le salaire des femmes
je sais pas si vous avez vu ce qui s'est
passé en début de semaine à washington
se battent danse du premier ministre
canadien justin trudeau avec l'éléphant
trompe d'éléphant 30 en anglais c'est un
autre sens en tout cas il y avait ces
discussions qu'ils ont eues va seul le
seul terrain d'entente pour ces deux
hommes politiquement très opposés ils
vont lancer un comité conjoint de
consultation pour l'avancement des
femmes entrepreneurs c'est quelque chose
mais une des grandes questions sera
évidemment de savoir pourquoi les femmes
entrepreneures par exemple au canada
font seulement 65% du salaire des âmes
parle évidemment des cadres de certains
niveaux
pour ce qui est des cadres un peu plus
moyen vous en connaissez la présence de
quelques zones où quelques-uns
l'écart est moins gras mais quand même
qu'on soit cadres ou non ont 60
travailleurs comme vous et moi
il ya un écart si on est une femme par
rapport à un homme dans notre pays c'est
peut-être le cas au canada c'est tentant
le savoir bonne question mais si vous
aviez les pouvoirs d'un président mieux
encore si vous aviez les pouvoirs d'un
premier ministre quel serait l'action
que vous pourriez poser pour réduire
complètement faire disparaître cet écart
fait travailler votre imagination
arriver avec des choses amusantes ou
réelle l'important c'est que vous puis
discuter avec nous autour du café cette
semaine on s'en reparle à facebook live
à partir de 11h vendredi à 12h15 dévoile
un petit panda
sinon on est à l'heure juste dès 6
heures le matin dimanche
dans notre version wii de youtube quoi
la mode zen